ah yes I love couch sitting so much
guess what I started doing Wordle Dude
Killing It 92 success rate okay so so
what what does that mean I missed one
out of 12 so far I've been doing for 12
straight days yeah he plays world so
what he gets mostly gets it in four or
five
but uh world is crazy it's at the
[ __ ] it's one of those things you go
to world.com or some [ __ ] and I'm doing
Wordle and I'm killing and having a good
time and then I [ __ ] tell my mom
about how I love Wardle and she's like I
love world two and then she goes like
this you ever heard of Squirtle and I go
like this Ma
this is like the time when you've I
don't this
my mom will do [ __ ] like this where like
I'm like we're like at dinner
and she's like do you know what you're
gonna get and I'm like yeah I think the
burger looks great and she'll be like oh
okay but they have Meatloaf I don't know
if you saw and now I'm conflicted dude I
already gave you a definitive answer but
you're gonna throw [ __ ] what I didn't
see the meatloaf and now I don't know
what I was totally happy and content
right
I am somebody that when the government
says we don't want to tell the public
this I go like this good don't tell us
this [ __ ] you'll figure it out that's me
at dinner and my mom's the government
like well we got to let the public know
they have meatloaf and now I'm the
general public population in turmoil
there's Mutiny going on inside me
half of me wants a burger and half of me
wants the meatloaf
so you know
she tells me about quartile and I'm like
at this point my mom says have you heard
of Squirtle and I go and honestly I'm 20
sure now that maybe my mom has actually
gotten senile because I'm like what are
you making [ __ ] up she goes there's four
four
squares there's not just one square
there's four of them and you keep
guessing letters and you have to get all
four and I go that sounds horrible and
she says it's fun
and I say all right I'll try it and I
try it that night and let me [ __ ]
tell you something dude when I tried it
that night dude I was doing that I mean
dude I was doing you can only do them
once a day what the [ __ ] up with
Wordle or quarter you can only do them
once a day that's [ __ ] I want one of
I want to do them more than once stop
gifting me this [ __ ] I know the idea is
to I don't understand it to me it's a
bad business plan like I want to do more
and more and more and more I want to
play it as much as I can dude when I did
Bananagrams I did it [ __ ] all day
imagine people saying that's like giving
one somebody one Lays Potato Chip I want
the whole [ __ ] thing and then I'll
eat more and then you'll make more money
right
but dude so I'm playing [ __ ] Wordle
and yeah it's fun and and then I [ __ ]
I'm like let me try this quartile thing
it's not gonna be good but sure enough
and now I'm playing World and quarterly
need some [ __ ] 25 minutes right
so I'm just like couch sitting doing
wordling chordal I see Mama my mom again
she goes
so was I right about quartile or what
and I and I said yeah quarto's actually
really great and we're sharing each
other at our scores you know our good
relationship with my mommy
and she says
you should try
OCT total
there's eight boxes hey
foreign
[Laughter]
craze dude leave it at quarto
I mean OCT Turtle doesn't even sound
good
is it about a [ __ ]
shelled animal
she goes you should try octoral it's
really fun and I say dude you know what
I can't I'm not I go I go OCT turtle
where's the [ __ ] thing come on it's
the
files done
come on man
so I didn't do octoadal yet but I have a
feeling [ __ ] next week I'm gonna come
in and be like yo oh Turtles the [ __ ]
dude that's how I do it I say nah [ __ ]
that [ __ ] cause here's the thing anytime
I'm like Russian dude anytime someone
says you should try this I go like this
what do you [ __ ] secretly want from
me are you a Cuda crazy
congratulations
[Music]
[Music]